[African children singing about the Maasai relationship with the land]
Stephen Pacala:
Hi, I'm Steve Pacala, the director
of the Princeton Environmental Institute.
Stephen Pacala:
In Princeton University's Grand Challenges Program
students, faculty, and all
Stephen Pacala:
members of the Princeton community
work together to try to solve
Stephen Pacala:
some of the most important problems that confront humanity
including problems of climate and energy,
Stephen Pacala:
sustainable development,
and global health.
Stephen Pacala:
The Siebel Climate and Energy Challenge
investigates the impact of fossil fuels on climate.
Stephen Pacala:
It ranges from climate modeling, to impacts of climate
change on rainforests and the oceans, to geopolitics of oil,
Stephen Pacala:
to the policies and politics of a solution, and new
energy technologies.
Stephen Pacala:
Students travel to the far corners of the world from
tropical forests, to the middle of the Pacific Ocean, to Saudi
Stephen Pacala:
Arabia, China, and the halls of Congress.
The Sustainable Development Challenge focuses on the East
Stephen Pacala:
African biodiversity, land use, poverty, and water.
It is based in our research facility in Kenya, but
Stephen Pacala:
also includes projects throughout Africa.
The work integrates studies of endangered wildlife, work with
Stephen Pacala:
local people, such as the Maasai, and has a particular
focus on water and land use.
Stephen Pacala:
In this region, everything depends on water.
The Global Health Challenge focuses on the epidemiology
Stephen Pacala:
of infectious disease,
the health of women and children, especially in
Stephen Pacala:
developing countries, vaccine development, and
antibiotic resistance.
Stephen Pacala:
Projects range from malaria in Africa to the risk of
a global flu pandemic.
Stephen Pacala:
The Program allows Princeton faculty
to redirect their research
Stephen Pacala:
and collaborate across disciplinary lines
and encourages participation among
Stephen Pacala:
all sectors of the University's academic community
including participation by graduate and
Stephen Pacala:
undergraduate students.
Emily Carter:
The beauty of the Grand Challenges initiative is
that it integrates the teaching and research and asks us
Emily Carter:
to think about how to enrich the undergraduate curriculum.
Craig Arnold:
These are concepts as scientists–we take for granted.
We learned all that. We know it. But to take
Craig Arnold:
someone who is a budding English major and give them
that little bit of knowledge—they now have so much more
Craig Arnold:
to go out. They can understand when we talk about
the challenges of "should we build nuclear plants?"
Craig Arnold:
The Grand Challenges–really, it brings
those people together. And, it gives them that little
Craig Arnold:
extra bit that students at Princeton deserve.
Kathleen Wade:
Hi, my name is Kathleen Wade. I'm a
Woodrow Wilson School major. I was funded by
Kathleen Wade:
the Development Grand Challenge during the
Summer of 2009. When I was working in Pune, India
Kathleen Wade:
I was working alongside another girl named
Devaki who was my age who had grown up in Pune.
Kathleen Wade:
And, it was a great experience to work alongside her.
I got to know her, and we became good friends.
Kathleen Wade:
It was really great to be able to be
in India and get an insider's view of what
Kathleen Wade:
the city is like through Devaki. And, we were
able to connect through our passion for
Kathleen Wade:
environmental issues.
Rohit Gawande:
Hi, my name is Rohit Gawande and I first received
funding from the Energy Grand Challenges Program
Rohit Gawande:
the summer after my sophomore year to do an internship
at ISLES Inc., which is a non-profit in Trenton,
Rohit Gawande:
New Jersey. My projects at ISLES mainly focused on
creating an energy efficiency program for local
Rohit Gawande:
residents and also teaching children at a local YMCA
about energy efficiency at their home.
Daniel I. Rubenstein:
What makes Grand Challenges so successful and so
novel is that it is providing a transformative
Daniel I. Rubenstein:
experience for both the researchers and the students.
Adjani Peralta:
At school we always learn a lot of theory and
we study a lot of papers, but to actually see
Adjani Peralta:
the papers in action in the community is what
I loved about my experience abroad. And, the
Adjani Peralta:
ability to come back here and try to make my
own impact on the community is what I really
Adjani Peralta:
appreciate from Grand Challenges.
Stephen Pacala:
The Grand Challenges Program is designed to
help solve some of the most important problems
Stephen Pacala:
that confront humanity by training a generation
of leaders committed to these problems.
Nisha Rao:
Just the issues that have come up during this
research I think will be very relevant to my
Nisha Rao:
senior thesis. I think the most interesting thing
I have learned is that: research can be very
Nisha Rao:
practical and can directly affect people’s lives
in a positive way and the effects of that research
Nisha Rao:
can be measured almost instantly.
Mathias Esmann:
What I liked the most about the Grand Challenges
Program was that it gave me the freedom to do exactly
Mathias Esmann:
what I wanted which was a non-traditional summer
project where I wasn’t interning in an office,
Mathias Esmann:
but I was working on the ground.
Stephen Pacala:
The Grand Challenges Program allows students
and faculty alike the opportunity to deliver
Stephen Pacala:
on the social contract, to make a difference
in the world today while still continuing what
Stephen Pacala:
Princeton has always done best.
[music]